[Music]
in want to play a game views no that's
all submitted by Stacey love you guys I
love your ghost basically a mother is
shocked after discovering a kids app
features a creepy voice joking about
knifing children I just saw this
yesterday that's a brief one Epis hell
is it candy crush no it's like a super
kids like for little kids yeah yeah so
this app is called call blaze and the
monster machines 2018 so this is what
the app looks like on the Google Play
Store
it looks like cars well this is an
actual TV show it's like on Nickelodeon
and stuff and then it even says here
that it's like rated for kids that's the
app and this is the video why the
robotic leprechaun no the [ __ ] how they
get kinda green is kind of scary wait
looking Lucky Charms guy fell off
actually saw the game and it's like yep
everything every time you pass like a
level yeah you you like call or whatever
and then like I guess after three or
four rounds it goes to that yeah they're
pretty much joking about stabbing the
kids I feel like it's one of those troll
games though to [ __ ] with people but why
why would
aim for kids like I same [ __ ] twisted
ass people are making these videos on
You Elsa gate yeah like Elsa and the
spider-man people where it's like
[ __ ] twist it and they know it
they're trying to prom attire to market
it towards kids yeah is there a way
where we can find the people that are
responsible for these things and play
with them all right cuz like if they get
a kick out of scaring people and doing
things like that then I would like to
put them in a room full of a toy room
that looks like a little kids room it's
decorated like a little kid and then you
shove all the toys up their ass I was
just gonna say put them in the room
every day you turn on the light and then
you have a little hole and like it'll be
like a bunch of spiders come out like a
bunch of hungry rats come out and bite
them
well like something is this app like it
has its own real purpose and then that's
just like a weird they may found or the
whole app trolls kids you made it like
that the whole app is like an innocent
game like what Joe was saying but then
once you pass these levels you get a
phone call from the character of that TV
show and this phone call was just like
that fucked-up one it's like if you were
playing Angry Birds and [ __ ] and and
it's like hey you're getting a call from
red angry bird and then you pick up the
phone and it turns into that all that
scary I'm so [ __ ] scared of having
kids nowadays shuffle yeah but then it's
like back then my games are not violent
and crazy whatever like and play
whatever games now like when I'm playing
games I hear about [ __ ] like in game
chat Nick on roblox
yeah on roblox they were talking to
children like they're [ __ ] pedophiles
trying to groom children and [ __ ] like I
want to share my love for video games
with my kids I want to do that but I'm
afraid of doing that because you never
know what's on there and I always tell
people like being attention what your
kids are [ __ ] playing when I was a
kid though I was looking for [ __ ] like
this we used to call 1-800 if you see
kusa all the time i remember you're like
a phone sex operator though you want to
make your dream but that's like you guys
are looking for that though you know it
shouldn't be readily available on things
that should even have it that's that's
probably like ten year old [ __ ] this is
like six-year-olds being exposed to
random chassis like I went to go visit
my family and like my little brother is
playing [ __ ] GTA no Mike why the [ __ ]
are you
to my parents I'm like why are you
letting him play this like this there's
hookers they probably don't even know
what it is exactly tell people now like
video games aren't what they used to be
you know like you need to actually pay
attention what your kids are [ __ ]
playing nowadays is really into playing
games and stuff but I blocked off the
fact that he can access messaging in the
internet like online playing he can't do
that he could only play with whatever we
have there I mean people used to think
pac-man was violent that's crazy because
it would eat the other and it's crazy
compared to what we have now yeah and
I'm just so afraid like I want my kids
to play games I want us to enjoy
together but I'm afraid of like getting
them into games and they play their own
thing
and I want together I just pictured you
guys like in the future though but like
uh you know her when he's playing the
game but he's like dig oh yeah that's
how you guys are playing hello y'all you
know me get good kid [ __ ] you kids don't
know how to just turn off that the kid
block thing you have to have a password
mm-hmm
do you think you would let your kids
play online [ __ ] oh good you know what's
bothering me it's a good question
bothering me every time we go to game
start trying to find a new game for
Isaac because we have all these
controllers for the three of us to play
together they have all these games like
they're making it more towards like if
you want to play with multiple people
you have to be online you can't play in
the same room you can't believe the same
room some games you can but they're
really hard to find Ellie they're really
trying to pull out the on lines yeah
heavily and I'm like can't you just have
some games for kids to play at home with
their friends like what the [ __ ] alone
yeah ISKCON where there are online
gaming now it's like it's like the big
thing it's eSports it's competition you
know but what about like a Wii well we
have an xbox well you know there's a lot
of games on icebox reading this play
story mode you know and just don't hook
it up to the Internet you can do that no
he can but it's just it's hard to find
games where we all the three of us can
play it's only one was especially on
Xbox too he's gonna need to know for
this game do it race game don't you get
him a Nintendo Wii we already have an
Xbox one what am I gonna be brain
launches by like three pairs of boxing
gloves you guys play that all day we
we did actually we have three pairs of
Rumble Rumble night I think for my kids
I would want them to play online
eventually just not early on because
people are [ __ ] weird online yeah
that's why when I found out about the
whole roblox thing I immediately I was
like I'm sorry I know you love roblox
but you can't play it yeah what's road
blocks you play it's like a character
you went around in the real world you
can talk to people and [ __ ] like that
and then people are messaging kids what
are you an yeah a pedophile like an
online arcade yeah where you can pick
different kinds of games for you to play
but you're playing with people from all
over the world and you have a character
that runs around so people are like
walking around characters and then
they'll be like hey make a character do
this thing and then like maybe like
little dance whatever and then they're
gonna get their characters stand behind
them and they're gonna dance I always
think they're humping so they're like
simulating and like this just kids game
yeah it's like The Sims yeah yeah yeah
kind of so it's like I I want my kids to
play online but at a certain age like as
a teenager because it's a crazy world
yeah it's [ __ ] scary out there you
know you know you could buy the whole
Nintendo or Sega Genesis like box and it
has all the games on there just give
them diabetes excuse me abacus dude not
like you just plays video games but it's
just you know that's an interest of his
it'd be nice if he had more options I I
think gave the Nintendo which is good
for him Nintendo is a more family like
your CD isn't all play together
Xbox more like competitive and like kind
of single player he recently got the
dimensions and he was like been about
that life a lego dimension I don't know
it's he was like all about it I love GTA
by the way I played almost every single
one since the beginning it was such a
revolutionary game and I think I got it
when I was 12
yeah and yet it was back then it was so
secret you had to like download it it
wasn't paid yeah like so like for this
mom she says that every time their kids
want to play like download a new
game she always plays at first and
that's how she was able to discover this
weird-ass feature about that's more
that's why she took a video of it push
it up and now Google has suspended the
app from Google Play so that's no longer
available and a spokesman said we have a
set of policies designed to provide a
great experience for users and
developers and we act quickly to remove
apps from Google Play that violate these
policies so do you think it's parents
that are being too paranoid because of
the violence and like realism is kind of
relative like for example when I used to
play duck hunt my mom thought I was like
straight-up murdering animals and so she
let me play duck hunt a [ __ ] dog yeah
but then now when you look at like Call
of Duty and stuff like you're murdering
human so people that are against Call of
Duty they're like can you play duck hunt
instead so I'm wondering is it just
relative to what the parents perceive it
as or like where do you really draw the
line I think it has to do with a lot of
how technology is improved and the video
games just looks so much more realistic
now now it's harder to decipher like
fake real yeah so like compared to now
duck hunt looks like a little cartoon I
think the problem with this specific one
is that people aren't getting it trying
to be like hey you know what happens
here it's like the heat calls you and
it's scary check it out it's me to [ __ ]
with kids heads
it's like randomly embedded in there if
this was marketed as like something
scary's gonna pop out right very
different from like they're
intentionally trying to [ __ ] with the
minds of children kind of like the
subliminal messages and Disney movies
did you guys ever see those oh yeah mix
in the side or like what dicks I feel
like that's just bored artists trying to
squeeze some [ __ ] in those Disney dicks
something about the carpet right or some
[ __ ]
and then you can hear someone in the
background saying Oh Katie is something
about like okay
kids take off your clothes or some [ __ ]
like that Wow really low in the movie
because I had that original VHS and when
I saw I saw it on the internet somewhere
it was like that [ __ ] so then I went
back and I looked at it I'm like oh [ __ ]
you could really hear it if you go to
the original post the cover for me
there's like little dicks drawn in the
castle because I feel like being the
artist there was just born so I can see
what I can get away with liking that
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
in fixing facebook news that's the
funniest thing I've ever heard
[Music]
you see no what's the funniest thing
I've ever heard
[Music]